foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work they love
and create amazing relationships I'm
Ramsay personality George Campbell
joined by one of the best friends a guy
could ask for Dr John deloney and we are
here to take your calls to help you take
the right Next Step whether that's with
your money your work your relationships
your mental health we want to see you be
well in all areas and John is an expert
at that for sure hey man I when it comes
to like being great friends I think I've
called you asking for your advice 100
more of the times you've called to be
fair your questions to me are money
questions if I'm asking you a question
it is like an hour of therapy that's
probably true so it's a different
situation that's fair so that's fair but
I'm going to uh play that card you got a
new baby coming so I will be asking the
phone lines are open at the deloney
house all the parenting advice from Dr
John he's figured it out just go ahead
and send it to uh John deloney.com ask
and we'll see if it gets through Jenna
and uh they won't let me trust you just
call myself they've screened my emails
and calls so the number to call Triple A
825-5225 if you want some advice you
want some confirmation affirmation we're
here for you Sal joins us up first in
Los Angeles Sal welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call how are
you guys doing doing great how can we
help
okay so my question I've been listening
to you guys for a while and I haven't
quite heard an answer on
um I'm in debt and I am trying to get
out of debt I'm doing going through the
baby steps I'm on step two and my
biggest problem is budgeting and my
question is how do I I need budgeting
tips for someone who doesn't make a set
regular income I am a bartender my
income fluctuates from night to night I
have I don't know I just don't know how
to set aside money when I don't know
exactly what's coming in cool how much
debt do you have
um I am sitting at about 13 000 right
now with about 10 000 a little more than
that in student loans
okay and tell me about this bartending
gig have you been doing this for a while
like what did you make last year doing
this
um let's see I made
so with just the bar I worked two jobs
so I work a morning job which is not
bartending as in my bartending with tips
and everything I pulled in
probably close to 75. amazing
and you think you'll do about the same
this year
um a little more I think
um through the bartending because uh
it's at a restaurant it's not at a bar
so we raised a lot of our uh menu prices
so we've just been seeing kind of an
influx in that cool okay so you're
talking about a regular income I love
that you're still wanting to do the
budget because a lot of people go well I
make a regular income the budget's
really not for me the budget is
especially for those with a regular
income it just looks a little bit
different for you you know what you're a
bad a bad night would look like right or
a bad month your lowest month what would
that be
I mean I do the math real quick because
it's not zero think of it on a nightly
basis then a monthly basis I think like
I think I average around 220 a night but
so but let's say per paycheck or so I
know it's different because of tips and
all that but on a bad week or two you
know you know I'm not going to make less
than a thousand bucks a week right sure
yeah so we can base on that our budget
and go all right if we're going to have
a prioritized spending plan which is
what you would have we're going to
prioritize our food shelter utilities
and transportation those things have to
get paid first what's after that what's
the next priority Insurance bills things
that have to get paid
right yeah like monthly stuff like just
phone or Internet or Insurance stuff
like that great and then beyond that
we're gonna go how much can we allocate
towards debt this month and each month
it's going to look different some months
you're going to be able to throw two
grand at that debt some months it may be
one grand
right and so that will help you start to
map this out and go okay I can't make a
perfect plan but I can make a
prioritized spending plan and now I'm
gonna have whatever's after that two
grand of expenses is all going to be
gravy I can throw it down so that's how
you want to set up your budget it's
you're just going to make a list of
priorities and go down the list until
you run out of money for that month
got it and then the Surplus just goes to
the debt exactly and dude making you're
making six figures right
um just under um with the second job
it's about 97. awesome so 13 Grand
making 97 how quickly can you pay this
off a few months before Christmas yeah a
few months for sure I'm thinking
sometime within the fall I love it dude
you're gonna be there so fast and you're
not scared of work Let's do let's don't
do sometime in the fall let's get really
specific like September one or at the
latest October one
and let's see if you can make that
happen I you hustle too hard man you
work too hard yeah you set that goal
yeah you're wired in there let's don't
be like ah sometime this fall October
one come hell or high water I'm having
this stuff paid off we're gonna make it
happen yeah if you say I'm gonna put
three grand a month towards this thing
and if you're short of that I'm gonna go
can I can I pick up an extra shift can
I'll take that hey they called out sick
I'll jump on that and that helps you
stay on track and stay focused this is
not about a balanced life you are living
an out of balance life you are living a
maniacal
lions are chasing me and I don't want to
die life until you get this debt paid
off good for you brother right crushing
it man I want to be like Sal when I grow
up that's impressive I mean to have the
two jobs a lot of people go well John I
can't do more I I can't do the two jobs
right what do you tell people who feel
like doing that hard thing is just John
I want to live my life man I don't want
to sacrifice that much all right I don't
work a second or third job
if I'm being totally honest I don't have
a lot of sympathy for that I don't have
a lot of sympathy for that
um I don't know I I just am not wired
that way
um my problem is on the other end is my
wife telling me
hey we've been running for 20 years
we're safe Slow Down slow down let's
let's live our life well you've looked
into the science and you talk about this
in Financial Peace University but this
idea that our brain is saying you're not
safe right there's something attacking
us an animal is chasing us and we're not
safe until XYZ and the problem with the
until is culturally speaking in
psychologically speaking that that until
that Benchmark that finish line moves
all the time right if I can just get ten
thousand dollars in the bank can you
imagine how that would feel and I'm I'm
coming to believe that most of us think
things are going to feel a certain way
when we get there if I just find the
right person the quote unquote the one
I'll feel it or if I just get my dream
job I'll feel it or if I just get a
hundred thousand dollars in the bank
I'll feel this way and we're so
disillusioned because in that feeling
never comes it's that feeling is not
real it's Hollywood it's an illusion and
so we don't know another way so we just
hit the gas and run harder trying to
find and Chase that feeling and that's
you get yourself into a lot of trouble
you burn yourself out you start chasing
feelings and you get one more drink or
one more drink or you start responding
to text of that person you're not
married to or whatever the thing is you
just start chasing that feeling that
feeling that feeling instead of
following a plan and I'm telling you I'm
the worst about it I'm the worst I love
that sense of feeling I love feeling
wired up I love feeling really low and I
don't like sticking to a plan that we've
all agreed on and this is what we're
gonna do the Cody the guy who runs my
life here at the office he's like hey
this is our plan we agreed and I'm like
yeah but what about this and this and
he's like golly man and my wife too so I
think it's the discipline is I don't
care how I feel I don't care the state
of my motivation here's what we wrote
down here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna make this thing happen that's what
I told him get a date on the calendar
and come what may hit that date and then
we're gonna figure out the next round
and we're gonna not move that Benchmark
on us all the time yeah squishy leads to
ish you can't spell squishy without s
Shawn I just made that up you just
delete that that's your Instagram for
the next five months more gold coming up
on the Ramsay show give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
baloney opened phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
well John big news big big news people
have been waiting for this uh they've
been worried about it and it's finally
official student loan payments will
restart in October can you believe it
yes the game of will they won't they is
no longer we can all stop wondering ah
jeez all right so I want to go back
through the history of this okay
um this is from this article here that
was uh by Andy Nova back in June 20th
um so president Trump first announces
the stay on federal student loans in
March of 2020. when the right when the
the pandemic hit
and then between Trump and Biden the the
pause has been extended eight times
says here nearly all people eligible for
the relief have taken advantage of it
with less than one percent of qualifying
borrowers continuing to make payments on
their debt oh boy number one that's
insane
I understand people pausing when right
when the pandemic kicked off and
everyone's got fired and everybody's
like hey you can't come to work I get
that
but over the last three years we've had
the lowest unemployment in the history
of the United States and we've had job
opportunities literally everywhere and
this thing has just been hanging over
people and George you and I have taken
the call over and over and over and over
again and for everybody else
you have it's it's late June so let's
say it's the beginning of July August
September you have a three to four month
Runway to prepare for this thing and
George nobody's gonna do it everybody's
going to wait until October and get so
mad oh my gosh this came and then we
gotta yes you borrowed money and you
signed your name to it you had to pay
all yours off yeah I had to pay six
figures of mine off it's just what we
did we signed up for it and now we're
all mad that they didn't make wave the
magic wand to make it go away and here's
one more funny thing George
if let's say Biden had been able to just
discharge all student loans
back when he wanted to a year ago
we would have already run up at number
of hundred million dollars nationally we
didn't stop because we didn't stop
making student loans we didn't stop
college right and so we'd be right back
on the path to where we are right now
and so all this is a big Quagmire of a
mess yeah I just looked at the recent
numbers we're at 1.6 trillion and part
of that is because nobody's paid off
their loans in the past three years so
the number doesn't change much it just
gets added too and uh the key here is
John while payments restart in October
interest starts in September
which means your student loan debt will
grow in Balance if you don't do
something about it and so if I were you
I wouldn't wait until September I
wouldn't wait until October I would
start paying it off right now find out
exactly how much you owe chances our
life has changed your loans could have
been sold to another servicer so you've
got to go figure all this stuff out and
get your head out of the sand and go we
got to make a plan and let's be really
clear about what this plan means and
um I think this is a Hallmark of this
show is we don't shy away from telling
you hard truth even when it's
uncomfortable for everybody
if you are one of the millions of people
who bought a car
on some sort of seven year note when
cars were super expensive and you were
able to make that loan work in your
household income
not including your student loans you
gotta you got three months to sell that
car period if you bought a big humongous
house and you didn't take into account
that you owe six figures in student
loans you're gonna have to sell your
house because they're going to take it
from they're gonna you're gonna lose all
this mess you got three to four months
to get on this thing but when we say
make a plan we don't mean like well I
guess we're gonna have to just stop
buying organic grapes this month for
millions of you this will be Shape
Shifter because you made long-term Plans
by borrowing money against the
depreciating asset in a car by buying a
house you couldn't afford with the idea
that these were just gonna magically go
away and they're not they're not
everyone was under the illusion that
they had an extra 400 bucks a month to
spend now because the student loan
payments are paused bad news these
aren't going away you can't even
bankrupt student loans go watch the
broad future documentary where we talk
to a lawyer who very scarily lets us
know just how difficult it is to
bankrupt under
George I
uh wow John up guys you riled delonia
it's just rare that I'm without words
um
please be a I I don't mean to do this
but I'm going to
um please be a person of Integrity when
it comes to October and don't head for
social media don't don't head to your
local Senator's office and scream and
yell
everybody knows this is coming everybody
else is coming and if you make payment
one in September and payment two in
October and the Supreme Court magically
wipes away 10 grand of this or whatever
fine you've still done the right thing
but you can't show up in October and
I'll say this as directly as I can you
cannot show up in October and be
surprised by this they're giving us the
government never gives us this kind of
warning they're giving us four months
and really they started telling us
there's a couple of months ago so we've
had five six
we've got plenty of time to do the hard
things that we have to do to make this
thing work and let this be yet another
validation of the Ramsay show stop
borrowing money stop our money stop stop
stop stop the way to live well we did a
a poll on the Ramsey Show YouTube
channel over 44 000 people took this
poll and it turns out 72 percent do not
have student loans
which if you're doing the math at home
that means over 12 000 of you who
actually follow us on YouTube you follow
this plan you still have those student
loans hanging around your neck holding
you down and here's a few comments from
YouTube that we got one person said I
took Dave's advice back in 2020 when the
payment pause started and I paid off my
student loans by the end of that year it
took a few sacrifices but it was
definitely worth it another one said got
wrote a student loan debt a month ago
it's awesome now putting extra money
into principle of my mortgage look at
that so it's possible for everyone to
pay off their student loans but let's
say this too
um we also know around around Christmas
time and into the new year there was
record levels of people putting
life on credit cards right and we knew
that there was record levels of spending
at the same time on
on what we would call Luxury items right
upgrading things and so it wasn't a
matter of people putting things on
credit cards to survive it was propping
up a lifestyle because inflation was
high and people wanted to continue to go
on vacations and continue to buy nice
things and continue the life that they
were living before when inflation was
Zero was very very low and so so many
people have continued to borrow their
way towards trying to prop up their
lifestyle and not factoring this in and
this 400 bucks dude this 800 bucks
whatever it's gonna however it's gonna
hit your household it's gonna be ugly
for folks who didn't prepare yeah well
they're saying a lot of folks are going
to default because they're confused on
what they owe they've been ignoring it
and see I don't they just hope it goes
away this article talks about the
confusion honestly I don't buy it
there's no excuse if this is me and I
haven't paid for three months for three
years I'm gonna go back to where I
started I'm gonna look at that payment
and I'm going to pay that payment on
September one period actually I'm gonna
pay that today but if I can't afford it
figure it out yes and pay what you can
pay but I'm going to start back at that
build don't just walk around I don't
know what to do I don't know what's it
that's like a middle school kid like I
didn't know I had to pick up my under I
have to change my underwear every day
yes every day it's it's just like that
don't make that dumb experience man I
don't yeah man maybe yeah this is I mean
it's frustrating it's frustrating John
for a while it's fun to point fingers
and go like well inflation and cost of
living have you seen the housing market
and John the president I mean to take a
look at this guy that's the reason for
all my problems instead of looking
inward looking at the mirror and going
hey maybe I am part of the problem maybe
it is my lifestyle maybe my debt
payments are killing me whether I see
them right now or not and so what are
the things we can control out of that
entire equation inflation cost of living
who's President the guy in the mirror
and maybe maybe I won't even go with
fault I didn't know what I was signing
when I was 18. I didn't know what I was
signing when I was 25 but I did and so
maybe even it's not a fault it's a who's
to blame
but this one person that can take care
of this and that's the person in the
mirror right and please please please
this is just your friend John talking
don't wait till October and act
surprised make a plan starting right now
it's not all your fault but it is your
responsibility do what it takes to
become debt free do what it takes to get
that freedom at all cost no matter the
sacrifice you will find that it was well
worth your time this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show
listen we have people who tune in to
every episode of this show and they know
all the stuff we teach about money they
could sit here at the desk and rattle
off the advice but they still feel
stressed out and they feel stuck why is
that well because knowing what to do
with your money isn't the problem
actually doing it as personal finance is
80 behavior only 20 head knowledge and
The Proven way to change that behavior
is by going through Financial Peace
University this is the class that's the
difference between trying to get in
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer you'll have a
coordinator holding you accountable and
other people in your class pushing you
on cheering you on and that's why this
class has worked for millions of people
after nine weeks nine lessons you will
never handle money the same way again
and you'll make progress faster than
ever so don't just listen to the show
and listen to this advice commit to
doing what it takes to win join an FPU
class at ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com FPU
all right let's go out to Candace in
Richmond Virginia Candace welcome to the
show
hi thank you
um my question
almost 6
debt and I am not sure where to go from
here
you call the right place okay so tell us
about this debt what what's made up of
the 60k
um so this was pretty Ramsey stuff um
but I have a HELOC
um I have a personal loan which was for
taxes
um because I ended up owing taxes uh my
car I have a credit card at 401k loan
um and then my phones
and then there's a little bit of um
uh medical debt as well I think you've
collected them all
yeah we're running out of types of debt
you could even go get okay
what is your household income right now
um it is
awesome okay is it just you
yes okay
cool so what are your next steps well
tell me about this what do you have
right now in the bank or things that you
could sell
um well I I do have my thousand dollar
emergency fund good
um and as far as things I can sell I've
already filled some tools out of my
garage and I'm going through the rooms
in my house
um trying to declutter so that I can
sell stuff and get it out awesome so
we're already on the right track and
what do you do for work
um I do arbitration for an insurance
company okay are you able to take on a
side hustle or two
yes well that's impressive you're
already crushing it is this a she in
daycare are he in daycare
um one is in school and one is in
daycare okay
but you're willing to do something even
if it's part time to try to create a
little more income because I'm looking
at the numbers here I'm going all right
60k in debt making 70. how much can we
throw with this debt you know 20 30k if
we're lucky right and that gets it done
in two or three years
right that's what we're looking at now
so I'm going how do we speed this thing
up as we start putting these into our
debt snowball smallest the largest let's
start attacking it but right now we just
need a bigger shovel compared to the
hole
right do you have uh any support or help
with your kids
it's all by yourself
what do you do for a living
um I work for an insurance company okay
right currently I'm working from home
but we are going back a couple of days a
week starting next month
what is that going to do to your
internal budget it's going to cost you
more in child care
um it's not going to cost any more in
child care but it's going to cost me a
lot more in gas because I live about an
hour and a half from the building oh
okay
um and and that was my bigger question
is this what you want to do long term is
there opportunities for you to begin to
at least throw some lines in the water
and see if there's not another 80 or 90
or 100 000 job out there instead of the
70 000 job that may even be closer to
you that may may allow you to stay uh
continue working from home if that works
for you but anytime I feel I just really
don't like the either or scenario and I
always at least want to try and see if
there's a third or fourth or fifth
option out there that I don't know about
the other thing I want to tell you how
old are your kids
six and three six and three okay
um have you been through it personally
over the last five six years
oh yes yeah
I'm sorry I hate that for you
um sometimes the Temptation in those
moments is to
pour every remaining ounce we have into
those kids as some sort of
protective prophylactic like a way to
try to insulate them from the hurt that
has been going on and it might still be
continuing to some degree inside that
house is that fair
yes I want to tell you the other side of
that
when you don't owe anybody any money and
mama is financially safe
there's a piece that courses through
that house it's the air that gets pumped
into that home that is restorative in a
way that you can only dream about right
now on this side of owing sixty thousand
dollars
I tell you that to tell you if there's
in a way if there's a way
that you can secure thirty thousand
bucks into side hustle fifteen thousand
dollars into side hustle
um and it's going to cost you a little
bit more in this or a little bit more in
that and it's going to cost you the most
expensive thing which is your time with
these little ones if you can do that for
a small amount of time
you do that for six months you do that
for a year you do that for 18 months the
back end
of having a home that is anxiety free a
home that is peaceful
um for those little little baby's
nervous system
um for your nervous system it's just
such a gift
and so I know the Temptation is to say
yeah but I've got these moments are so
precious and God they are but man whole
peaceful moments on the back end are
they're just worth their weight in gold
right right so if you can find it go for
it
I I'm not opposed to another job no I
know you're not I don't like change yeah
I know I know
um you've been through enough for the
last few years
and and I've been with my job for 17
years but um I I do want to get out I
don't want to do this I don't like the
direction they're going
um I've never needed a resume I don't
even know how to do a resume well we got
you so here's what I want you to do I
want you to stay on the line we're gonna
I'm gonna send you a couple of things
I'm gonna um send you uh we're gonna
send you a link to Ken Coleman's Resume
Builder it's going to walk you through
there's a bunch of resume templates
there and I'm going to send you his um
get clear assessment that says okay I've
got this skill set I've been doing this
job for this long what are some other
things I might be interested in what are
some other things that might be
instantly qualified for what are some
things that I'm really close and I just
need to go get some more education get
some more schooling and I'm right there
um so I'm going to send you that and
we're going to send you his book
proximity principle which is this simple
way of getting connected with people in
your local community who may be doing
the job that you want to be doing and
how do I reach out and make that thing
happen is that cool okay yeah so hang on
the line here we're gonna get you taken
care of I love it and Candace what is
the car worth versus what you owe
um my car payments 170 4.96 a month okay
I might consider if you sold that thing
you'd have 10 grand to go buy yourself a
nice cash car that could get you from A
to B just fine while you get out of this
debt and it might help you see the light
at the end of this tunnel
if you can clear 10 of your debt next
week it will give you a little bit of
Hope and I think that's what you need
right now is a little bit of proof that
this stuff actually can work that you
can get out of this and then start doing
the math going all right if I'm going to
try to get rid of this debt in two years
that's you know 25 or 30k a year that's
2500 bucks a month how do I make up that
much margin through spending less and
making more and that will help you stay
on target so you're not just hoping and
wishing instead you go I'm going to be
debt free two years from now no matter
what come hell or high water I'm gonna
be there
and on top of all that stuff we just
gave you I'm going to gift you one year
of Financial Peace University and one
year of every dollar premium
so that you can start to map out that
plan map out your income get encouraged
by the videos you can join a virtual
class online
you need a gang to walk with you're
doing this alone right now and you don't
have to there's millions of people who
are on the same Journey who can
encourage you who can get you connected
to other places and give you some ideas
that's what this is all about so hang
online we're about to send you a whole
bunch of stuff and I hope it gives you a
little bit of Hope pun intended so thank
you so much for the call Candace we are
cheering you on this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you're a new listener to the show and
you want to dive deeper into the baby
steps into the stuff we're talking about
you can go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the get started button and we
will help you figure out the next best
step for your financial Journey based on
where you're at today that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services you can trust
neighborly's local service providers to
repair maintain and improve your home
visit neighborly.com to find experts in
your area and schedule services today
all right today's question comes from
Rachel in Oklahoma Rachel writes why
does getting current on my four walls
and Necessities in baby Step Zero feel
like the most emotionally draining thing
in the world to get through
my financial situation feels taxing and
heavier than it's ever been how do I
work through this and remain hopeful
George you're kind of the baby Step Zero
um originator man yeah I remember being
here back in 2013 when I first started
this plan
and I think what she's describing here
is having to Face Reality potentially
for the very first time like looking in
that Financial mirror and going
oh my gosh this is what all the bills
add up to versus my income and this is
the actual debt totals and here's the
interest rates and here's all the fine
print and all the statements and it just
feels overwhelming like the walls are
coming in on you and the key is you
can't stay there we can't we the plan is
not hey just look at it all and then
just you'll be all right the plan is
what do we do from here what do we do
how do we make a plan how do we get on
that budget how do we make a plan to get
rid of the debt and that's where you
start to feel some hope
and John you speak to kind of facing
that reality and grappling with
sometimes what you didn't want to see in
that mirror yeah there's no way towards
emotional Wellness or even physical
wellness spiritual illness unless you
take an inventory where you are right
and so there's something powerful about
getting that first blood test back from
a reputable doctor and they sit you down
and they go whoa right there's that
first time you sit down with a counselor
I'll never forget sitting down with Dr
Smith and just just vomiting for two
hours here's all that's going on and he
sat down I mean he was sitting down and
he said hey man here's what it sounds
like is going on and he nailed me to the
wall and he was right and I didn't want
to believe it right or there's those
moments I've had in my marriage when it
is almost
it's it's hanging on barely and we my
wife and I both had to sit down and say
okay what are we gonna do next is this
it is this it are we calling it or are
we gonna have to control delete and
rebuild this thing from the floor up and
those moments are never fun and they're
never glorious and they're never
exciting
um I love how Rachel says it it feels
like it's emotionally draining yes it is
owning reality is the worst that's why
honestly you cannot do it alone
effectively right
um there's great internet stories about
like I just went to the gym and I
started crushing it and four years later
you know I lost 700 pounds that happens
that's not most of us most of us need
somebody to sit with us or a couple of
people and say yeah it's emotionally
draining
here's what the next right move is and
that's one of the keys to Financial
Peace University what I think makes it
so powerful and so successful is not
because man those lessons just they're
exactly yes the knowledge is there and
it's very motivating to watch the videos
but a key component is accountability
and community and structure I gotta show
up once a week and they're gonna wonder
why I didn't show up to that next class
that accountability that Community going
oh I'm also not alone other people have
done dumb stuff too half of you
listening to the show listen because
you're like oh I'm not that bad that
makes me feel better that person's crazy
yeah I'm out of control a little bit too
but we need to know that we're not crazy
we're not alone other people can win
those people look like me I can do this
too and so if that's you get connected
with other people get connected to an
FPU class it makes all the difference
and if regardless of what type of of
reality you're having to face that
you're you're in an abusive relationship
and you're not doing this anymore or
that your kid is not okay or
um that you're tired of being overweight
and now you're going to make some
significant changes whatever that
reality is
um
please reach out and get somebody to sit
with you whether you've got a couple of
trusted friends whether you've got a
professional whether it's a nutritionist
or a counselor or doctor get somebody
with you that will help you with some of
the reflection as you work your way
through it it's tough it feels taxing
and heavier as Rachel says um than it's
ever been yes reality will do that to us
the other beautiful thing about going
through the clock FPU class or sitting
with a professional is they can show you
all of the people who were set right
where you are and they're a success
story after success story after success
story millions of people have been right
where you are and so there's you may not
see the light at the end of the tunnel
but you can head off into the darkness
knowing that it's there good word thank
you for the question Rachel let's go to
the phones Catherine joins us up next in
Pittsburgh Catherine what's going on
hi uh I'm a little bit nervous but um
you're all right take it easy yeah have
you heard me and George there's really
nothing to be nervous about here
yeah so my question is uh my husband and
I have been married for about a little
less than two years and he's about to
enter grad school for about three years
for three years
and I will be limited on the amount of
work I can do
and I'm just getting really anxious and
scared about it how come why is it why
is his grad school attendance impacting
your ability to work
so
um I'm about to have a baby and then
where we're living
there we're not near any family and
there's limited daycare options ah and
he will be working probably in clinical
probably 60 hours a week yes that kind
of limits him
um I'm gonna ask a crazy question call
me ignorant yeah why is right now the
time for him to go to grad school
well we've been planning on it so for
the past year and eight months we've
been saving pretty aggressively we've
saved about 230 thousand dollars wow and
so I but I'm still just in so much fear
that it won't be enough because we're
trying to cash flow
School what's the program 118 is a nurse
is going to be a nurse anesthetist okay
so that's that's expensive because you
already have a master's or a bachelor's
in nursing
so we paid off seventy thousand uh
during our engagement for his one of you
for his bachelor's in nursing okay and
then when we got married we
basically just saved my entire income
for the past almost two years
um to prepare for school so we could
cash flow it while also knowing our
program be pregnant and have limited
capacity to work how much of how much of
your inner inner angst is
related to the fact that you're going to
be moving and starting a family
and a sense of impending
loneliness you're gonna be all by
yourself
I think it's just like a lack of control
like I feel like I've I'm definitely the
planner in the relationship and just the
lack of
um
because it sounds like you've planned me
really you've planned better than 99.9
percent of the people that call this
show I feel like it's never gonna be
enough yeah and um that statement right
there that's your anxiety talking that's
not reality because the reality is
Catherine and her husband plan
incredibly well
and Catherine and her husband have have
been through it you had to pay off 70
grand that's a lot that sucked and then
you turned around and saved 230
000 on the back end so that never
happened again
and you're having a baby which for you
controllers you planners those calendars
go right out the window when that baby
cries we got to deal with it right and
that baby wakes up we got to deal with
it and so there is a total loss of
control and there's also a loss of
control when you move to a whole new
state in a whole new city just as one of
the most transitional moments of your
life is happening right all that's true
the work I think ahead of you is how can
I get plugged into a group of young moms
in my new community
so that I don't wake up and it's been
four months and the only other living
person I've seen besides this four month
old is my exhausted
um in clinical rotation husband
yeah that sounds like the work ahead of
you because you've taken care of the
money part y'all are doing great and on
the financial side have you guys done a
budget with just your income even
part-time to go are we gonna be able to
cover all the bills for the next few
years yeah we probably have to find
another way to pay for insurance because
right now it's 600 a month
um
but yeah for the most part and here's
the deal here's the deal there is a
possibility let's say you all sat down
and like we just talked about in the
previous segment you got to own reality
we're going to do a hard budget and he
might need to postpone
um his enrollment for one year and any
program in the country will let him do
that
um he can put he can punt it for one
more year and save up the money or he
may tell the admissions person that and
they may say well dude we'll just write
you a scholarship then it will help you
out because they need the enrollment
numbers these days so it's just about
owning reality and just being very clear
on that budget thanks for the call
Catherine that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button will help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls
about life money relationships mental
health Wellness you name it at this
number eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Zach joins us up first
in Kansas City Zach what's going on
hey how's it going great how are you
hey not too bad
um just giving you guys a call here I
kind of got myself in a kind of a
strange financial position here and
wondering if I need to sell my vehicle
in order to kind of reset you know my
life and uh you know kind of get out of
a hole that I put myself in
um I can kind of I can go into this
specific specifics of uh exactly what
happened
the way you're the way you're starting
the call off
um sounds like you are dealing with
shame what what what has happened here
well I'm 24 years old
um I'm two years out of college and
unfortunately I kind of got you know
hooked up with the wrong people and what
I mean by that is as I started uh
gambling Sports gambling casino gambling
and
not that I've lost a ton of money but
it's definitely money that I probably
could have used and spent better I lost
about eight thousand dollars in about a
six month span that's a ton of money
yes it's a lot of money and that's
and I definitely take it on the chin
what I did was irresponsible it was
immature and 100 something that is
self-inflicted and that I did myself
well you are correct and
I also want to suggest that
we live in an ecosystem now that has
made gambling
um seem like the right thing to do
it really helps out the education system
in your particular State it's a fun way
to hang out with your friends and if you
look at the addiction statistics and the
amount of money being spent on this it's
as though your colleges and universities
which have absolutely sold their
freaking souls to this
are just all you know it's a great great
way to spend a weekend with your kids
you all should do heroin together y'all
should all do cocaine it would just make
you all get a lot more work done and
talk a lot faster it's insane
and so in this in a similar fashion
brother yes you did some dumb things and
you're unfortunately you're one of
millions of of other men and women who
are stuck holding the bag on this deal
and at the same time
um since you were 18 years old and you
showed up at this college everyone
around you from your local government
officials to the university that you
attended has told you what a great and
wonderful thing this is and so that's
been in the air you're breathing too so
I I want to it's both and right
yes so how much debt do you have
well I you know the good news is is I
don't have much I have some I do have it
written down and I can kind of go over
it with you and let you know
um exactly where everything is broken
down into okay what's the total
yeah so I have roughly I would say
everything together right around 50 000
in debt that's between student loans
auto loan and just credit card and
that's not much to you
here's the thing I have 17 000 in
student loans I have just under a
thousand in credit cards and thirty
thousand uh auto loan and other than
that that's the only debt that I have
all these words are just the it's the
only debt I just have we got to stop
using these modifiers I want you to feel
like holy crap this is a lot of debt
I am not safe this isn't only a thousand
dollars on the credit card this isn't
only seventeen thousand this is my life
at stake my future hangs in the balance
that's the kind of intensity you need to
be feeling towards this debt if we want
to get out of this hole because if it's
only a thousand then why even pay it off
I mean it's really not even that it's
it's almost zero at that point so I want
you to start to change those words that
you're using to trigger your own brain
to tell yourself I'm not okay
something's got to change
okay are you still gambling now
no I'm uh
just shy of 60 days clean awesome are
all the apps off your phone you don't
have any access to them or anything
no I threw I threw away so when I was
physically going to the casino I had a
player's card and whatnot so all of
those have been trashed um I haven't had
the urge to go I never
um really got involved in online
gambling other than just sports betting
through DraftKings that app has been
deleted
um but I have no
um I guess there's nothing at my
fingertips that can allow me to gamble
have you transferred that initial
addiction onto something else are you
drinking more than normal or staying up
later more than normal
no um I I'm not I've never really been a
drinker I would say the most I ever
Drank in one sitting was probably maybe
a six pack of beer I just really am just
not really into getting I'll say this I
I spent some time I spent some time in
college hungover and it's a feeling that
it's just not uh not something I enjoy
okay well I wasn't focusing less as much
on the alcohol as much as right if we
tell you to sell your car
and you are if you're calling us and you
don't have a gambling addiction
and someone says hey should I sell my
car to get me out of debt and I can
still get my job done I'm working from
home I'm making this kind of money we
might tell you heck yeah I do sell your
car
if you're an addict
if you're really struggling with
addiction
um and we tell you to sell your car
that's good it's just gonna duct tape
over the problem until tomorrow and it's
going to re-emerge somewhere else and so
if you tell me hey man I had a phase in
college I went bananas I learned an
eight thousand dollar lesson I got hit
in the mouth I'm done with that then
that's that's one path if you tell me
man I am struggling I want to gamble
every day I'm not there yet then we're
going to take another path
right what's your income not that I'm
trying yeah so my income as of last of
24 years old I'm a Freight Logistics
broker
um as of last year my gross pay was 88
000 great what's the car worth
uh it's worth roughly about fifty five
thousand yes sell it so you're gonna net
25 you're gonna get a real reasonable
car that is not twenty five thousand
dollars probably a ten thousand dollar
car that gives you an extra 15 to pay
off more debt and now we're going to be
debt free within a few months making 88.
that's what I was thinking too but you
can't spend more than 10 grand on a car
so ten thousand is where it needs is the
is the cutoff and I just made that
number up but I want it to be a car that
you're gonna have to like kind of duck
your eyes when you walk into your office
and everyone will be like dude we know
how much you make why are you driving
that car
right and here's the reason I need that
you you've got to have that carrot
dangling of like man I want to upgrade
this car once I'm out of debt and I have
that emergency fund I'm gonna upgrade
this car and the next time I own a car
that I like it's not gonna own me but
hey I want to ask you before we get off
the call you're still you're you're in
path one that we talked about you're not
you're not considered a gambling you
don't have an addiction you're done with
that mess is that fair
just here that's correct all right cool
congratulations my man I'm proud of you
that's a big step the hardest part is
done now we just got to clean up this
mess it's not meth not meth at all John
this mess addiction talk uh clean up
this mess man get rid of that car get
something reasonable get out of debt so
much faster by doing all that and uh
call it a get out of jail free card and
never go back into debt again
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show
I know a lot of you are planning to move
sometime soon and that is awesome I'm
excited for you but I gotta be real in
most places around the country you're
still facing sky-high home prices and
interest rates well they're not exactly
returning to record lows and that
doesn't make home ownership impossible
though if you want to buy or sell you
just got to make sure you're financially
ready and you've got a trusted and
experienced real estate Pro to walk you
through it not a family friend who just
got their license last month not someone
who does Real Estate as a part-time
hobby you need a pro who's a true expert
in the local market and knows how to
negotiate a strong deal you can find
those High Caliber Ramsay trusted agents
through our endorsed local provider
program and since we vet these folks
around the country you're going to have
the best support whether you're moving
from Florida to Alaska or buying your
first home somewhere in between go to
ramseysolutions.com agent to find a
Ramsay trusted real estate agent today
that's ramseysolutions.com agent
Carol joins us up next in DC Carol
welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call can you
hear me okay yes you sound great what's
going on okay so my husband and I are
about 96 000 in debt we're looking to
move back to Texas to be closer to
family I have two small children one and
three years old and we have no family up
here in DC
but the caveat to that is he has two
daughters from a previous marriage who
are here we're wanting to move back to
Texas sell the house that'll completely
pay off our debt we'll downsize in-house
about a hundred thousand dollars uh
minimum and then be closer to family
where I can start working full-time
again and increase our income I'm trying
to reconcile my guilt and a bit of
resentment that I'm building uh being
feeling trapped up here in DC
oh Carol how honest can I be with you
yeah open up are you sure
yes
all right
um you've number one you've got to
change your language because your
language is dishonest
you do have family in Washington DC
because you married a man with two
daughters
very true you don't have
um biological family there but you do
have family there
and you can feel trapped but the only I
mean you walked into the Trap and said
it yourself you married a guy and with
it with family
are you feeling disconnected from your
family in Texas or are you looking at
Texas as a golden ticket to solve all of
your financial problems no my main goal
is to my children don't know their
family him and I both have a family in
Texas
um too and our two youngest daughters
they don't they don't really know them
and I see that as a challenge
yes but I also see them not knowing
their half-sisters I also see your
husband not be in the lives of his
daughter biological daughter exactly
that's where my guilt is coming from so
tell me about this guilt
I don't want to
take I think that's the right move
how does he feel about this as you guys
talk about it
we've we've talked about it he does want
to move back to Texas and we were you
know playing with a plan of visitation
and what that would look like him flying
up every month to see them
so he's never actually said hey I'm
doing this for you but I really don't
want to do this he's on board you guys
are alive he does want to move to Texas
yes
but you're just feeling personal guilt
even though he's never put that on you
it's just more like I feel this for him
on behalf of him
yes well I would think about how I would
feel with him missing my two children
and how my kids would feel
that's good I'm going to tell you
empathy I'm gonna tell you
oh man I
I can't wrap my head around a scenario
where I would move across the country
away from my daughter
and try to reconcile that let me put it
this way
um after about a week I'm unable to
Breathe Right without my daughter around
exactly and so I can come up with all
sorts of schemes to try to make myself
feel better
but I'm telling you right now after
having worked with young people for 20
plus years
the question these young girls are going
to ask and they're going to be right to
ask that question when they're old
enough is what was so important about
taxes that you left us
yeah
and that's not a question as a dad I
want to ever have to answer
and so I I get man you miss your family
or you want your kids to know your
family I I would much rather see you
take your kids to Texas once a month if
that was so important to you my wife my
whole family's from Texas I'm from Texas
my wife's whole family she just did a
tour of Texas seeing my family her
family
um that's that's part of our annual
pilgrimage we call it every year that's
part of our life and I want my kids to
know their cousins and I want my kids to
know their grandparents and Texas has
very very distinct Texas cultural things
I want them to know all that stuff
but we live here
and
I
I'm gonna tell you man I I just can't
see a scenario where that works out long
term for your marriage for your husband
for those little girls
yeah and and again I know it's not what
you want to hear and I know you see you
also have begun the the golden ticket
thing like well if we did this we would
pay off all this and pay off all this
and pay off all this Washington DC is
such an incredibly expensive place to
live it's a chaotic place to live it's
zoning is a zoo like everything I get it
I get it I get it I get it
and yet that's where his two baby girls
live
and so if I'm you I am taking this is
just me I'm speaking to you as though
you were my close friend or you're my
sister or you're like whatever
I'm taking that off as a variable off
the table the same way George and I tell
people to take debt off the table I'm
taking that off the table I'm not going
to voluntarily ask my new husband to
leave his daughters because I want my
two little kids to know about Texas I'm
not gonna do that
um I'm gonna take it off a table and
then we're gonna try to figure out do we
need to move 30 miles outside of town to
make it more affordable for us do we
need to downsize for a season what does
our life need to look like because this
is the our life and you have to start
changing your language to say this is
our life this is our family not just you
did this and you've got these kids and I
wish we didn't have them or I didn't
have them you do okay you opted into it
and the more the quicker you make peace
with that the more division you're going
to have in your the less division you're
gonna have in your own soul much less in
your own marriage
is that fair it is yeah I know it sounds
like I'm between harsh man but but yeah
we actually did move uh further outside
of the city uh to be closer to them
um with the understanding that we would
get to spend more time with them we are
dealing with a difficult ex-wife as well
so and there's that let's let's just
call space Spade your life would be
easier without dealing with her wouldn't
it oh 100 yes that's not the case and
those two little girls that's right I'm
worried about it's my stepdaughters yeah
how how old are these girls
they are
okay mine are one and three so you're
talking about a 10-year plan
a 10-year plan for us to transition back
to Texas
which feels like a hundred years until
you think back how old are you now
I'm 37. yeah I think back to when you
were 27 that was like five minutes ago
wasn't it
yes it was just a second ago so you're
gonna snap your fingers and be 47 and
you're gonna have two
um uh like an 11 to 12 year old run
around your house and you're gonna have
two a 17 year old and a 20 year old 17
year old 19 year old and then y'all
start your transition back if you still
want to do it then that's that's that
would be my recommendation yeah again
y'all do what you want but that'd be my
recommendation okay
so much for the call Carol George those
are hard man because there's
it feels like everything would be better
if and it I'm I I'm just telling you
when you divide up families when you
split time from Partners when you split
time from kids
this it always has a price to pay well
always has a price it's going to be hard
either way but in our minds we go if we
just did that thing it would be so much
easier correct but you still have to
figure out travel plans and they got to
go back and it's still going to be and
not to mention I just always want to
fast forward to that 18 year old girl
sitting across a diner table from her
dad saying why did you leave me and
that's a that's never a question I want
my daughter to have to ask me that's a
good word John more of your calls coming
up money life relationships mental
health Wellness it all happens right
here on the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney this
hour this is the Ramsey show free call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five you call us we'll talk about
your life your money your relationships
your mental health and wellness all of
it well John this uh article has been
the Talk of the Town from Big Tech Apple
worth 2.6 trillion dollars and here it
is from Forbes why Apple's partnership
with Goldman is the future of banking
all right let's let's don't blow by that
2.6 trillion dollars yeah I was joking
during the break that that is they're
worth more than all of federal student
loan debt in the nation plus all credit
card debt in the nation combined so they
just liquidated themselves they could
just they could help us out come on
Apple do us a solid be a bro Tim Cook
come on TC let's just like be a hook us
up let's just company you guys have done
a public good you could wipe out all
credit card debt and all student loan
debt today and they'll be back to a
trillion dollars in Revenue I would I
would commit to buying an iPhone for the
rest of my life if you guys took that
kind of took that kind of stand that's
all I'm saying I love it well here's why
they're they're being talked about as
the future of banking uh they
effectively dropped the mic on the
nation's banking industry according to
this article by releasing a new
high-yield savings account that is only
available get this John two customers
with Apple's credit card
talk about a genius plan oh you want
this little high yield savings account
open up a credit card first and then you
can have the 4.15 interest on your
savings well I think they're probably
going to try to do away with the
distinction between a debit card and a
credit card and just roll it all
together
um one massive thing just here's a it's
even do away with the idea so it may be
that our kids don't even know what a
card is it's just on their phone right
it's on some sort of digital chip or
some sort of something but you just wave
it over the thing and if you got money
in there it pays for it if you don't we
will cover you with a credit and you're
good to go well and here's the thing
there's so we've got a video to show you
kind of some of the advertising around
this but the users can set up an account
in minutes and uh check their spend
rewards called daily cash which is
funneled into this high yield savings
account and the account is displayed on
a dashboard and Apple's digital wallet
where users can track their balance and
interest and this product allows Apple
to offer yet another sticky iPhone
benefit by strengthening its built-in
digital wallet and uh executive
president of financial services for a
consulting firm said it's really a
flywheel of keeping everything in the
ecosystem
yeah you think Apple wants to own you in
every way shape and form uh this is not
the only thing they've done John because
yes you say it's been it's been
everything's been moving this way with
this idea of
I'm you know people are sick of carrying
a wallet and a phone and an iPad
anything let's just put it all in one
thing so put the Apple credit card in
the Apple digital wallet you don't even
need to carry it inside the phone but
you carry the card because it's titanium
John and all your friends are super
impressed right your metal cars they'll
be even better if I just wave my my
digital magic Harry Potter so heavy it's
so metal you want real heavy metal
listen to Iron Maiden don't get an Apple
credit card ah I'm more of a Pantera guy
but Iron Man's fine Ryan holiday loves
Iron Maiden well here's the thing this
is just one of many steps Apple's taking
and they're not they're no longer a tech
company they're a fintech company
Financial technology and they also
release this new Apple pay later which
is their version of buy now pay later
and here's where they're genius John
you can't get charge interest right
there's no interest no fees well how
does Apple make money number one through
interchange fees they charge to business
owners every time you swipe that that
card or use their buy now pay later
service and the other way is by your
account overdrafting
because of course when you made 19
different transactions with Apple pay
later and you forgot and all of a sudden
you're Bank overdrafted who is the point
the finger pointed at your bank for
overdrafting Apple's not the bad guy
it's the bank's fault for these
overdraft fees it's out of control or
look in the mirror and go this is my
problem
I can't this is not a good money
management system to do Apple pay later
and use the Apple credit card to get the
high yield savings just skip the the
ecosystem entirely and own your own
future well and let's let's the ethos of
apple has been let's take over
industries that are moving too slow
and I think there's a case to be made
for we're seeing bank failures there's
they're so slow to operate and
everything's got to run through these
state and federal organizations
um they did it to Communications they
did it to music and there was some talk
they were going to do it to higher ed
and now they're moving over to the bank
industry it doesn't surprise me but man
it feels a lot it feels a lot like Sears
when Sears had the corner on stores like
where you went and bought goods and
services and as they they begin to lose
their grip on the Monopoly if you will
of goods and services stores they
shifted to another way to make money and
after a while they just became a credit
card with some stuff out front and I'm
wondering if the days of nobody had ever
heard of an iPod all of your music on
one tiny little thing and then all of
your the phone and then the iPad was
magic that I the the MacBook Pro was
magic
Apple watch is cool I wonder if they're
looking in the mirror going dude we just
can't just make we can't just reinvent
the world every few years we gotta move
to another industry and we're gonna
slowly start to transition our company
to we're a credit card company with some
shiny stuff out yeah and to hear me say
I'm not an apple hater I used to work at
the Apple Store if you can't tell I look
like every Apple employee you've ever
seen in your life uh I all Apple devices
all over I mean I I love their product
but you're turning into the product
America when you sign up for these
high-yield savings accounts with the
credit card and use Apple pay later and
it's all slick and it's all frictionless
and all of a sudden you're broke
wondering okay I have a titanium card
but I have nothing in my bank account
this is a problem so don't fall for the
traps that apple is setting out for you
I'm fine if you use the products just
not their banking products stick to you
know a normal bank for that all right
let's go to the phones Amy joins us in
Dallas Amy welcome to the show
hi
um quick question and please explain uh
your answer why that's my main question
but um
George so so please um because I can't
get my head around the math okay
um is it better to utilize my HSA as an
investment account or leave it as is for
you know Medical
expenses as I need
that's a great question yeah so what
you're talking about for those that
don't know what the conversation we're
having this is a health savings account
that is tied to a high deductible health
care plan and I love the HSA if you've
listened to the show for any amount of
time because of its triple tax benefits
so you can put money in tax-free the
money grows tax-free you can withdraw
the money tax-free and another benefit
is you can invest the money once you hit
a certain threshold so for example it
might be a thousand dollars when you
have over a thousand dollars in that
account any money beyond that can be
invested just like your 401k into gross
talk mutual funds so you're saying hey
should I leave the money in there to
grow or should I use it for health care
expenses
correct I'll tell you what Dave Ramsey
does and what other wealthy people do
when they're able to cash flow as
medical expenses they leave it and they
use it as another wealth building tax
advantaged account as part of their
strategy and so if you're able to cash
flow the math works out to where you're
better off letting compound interest
work its magic on the investment side
and you just cash flow those medical
expenses out of pocket
yeah so the math that you're talking
about I assume is well the HSA is tax
deductible and so I could save on that
side but I'm also kind of gaining on the
compound interest side is that what
you're talking about
yes okay yeah I mean I'm trying to think
do I think of it more of a almost like a
529 like obviously I could cash flow
college but there's a reason why I'm
saving for that now and for 20 years
before my kids turned 20
um or 18 but I don't know I'm trying to
wrap my head around I personally Max my
HSA out and I I spend out of it both
right I've got two little kids that are
accident prone I'm accident prone like
like and so it's a it's an investment
vehicle that I get to withdraw from
that's the way I look at it
okay so you can do both really like an
emergency fund but like an investment
vehicle that I also yeah yeah and I
guess that's a third option do I do both
right yeah emergency happens I can
easily pay for an emergency yeah if I
wake up in 20 years and it has I've
saved more than I've spent that's
awesome and you also hopefully have the
emergency fund and so you can also use
that to dip into the cash flow expenses
and leave that money there the other
cool benefit is that once you're of a
certain age I believe it's 60 or so you
can kind of use that account as like a
401k you can use it for things Beyond
Healthcare expenses uh you just won't
get some of those tax advantages so it's
a great tool you can crunch the numbers
but I wouldn't sweat it you're in such a
great place use it if you have to leave
it if you don't need to this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney this
hour the number to call is triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey if
you like this show do us a quick favor
the show is free and what I'm asking you
to do is free please consider hitting
the Subscribe button hitting the follow
button leaving us a review wherever
you're listening and sharing this with a
friend
Dave always jokes that we have about
zero marketing budget for the show
because you guys are the marketing
budget by telling your friends about
this and if you're like me and you see
these numbers with people borrowing
money to prop up their lifestyle you see
people struggling to get out of debt or
falling for payday lenders or whatever
is going on and you just get so
frustrated it's honestly George when we
sit down with people it's almost always
a matter of Education teaching somebody
and they go oh my gosh so many people
have said yeah I heard Dave Ramsey 20
years ago and I it's just it's just been
a thorn in my side because I knew you
can't unhear it I don't see it and if
you will just do something as simple as
like or subscribe to the show leave a
five star review it just throws this
show up in people's feed and it gets
that information all over the place it's
more effective than any billboard we got
because it's such a personalized
experience and it's just simply you
going I want to change my community for
the better like And subscribe ta-da and
you've helped your community for the
better it's that easy thank you for
doing that George joins us up next in
Columbus Ohio George welcome to the show
hey George hey John thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's going on
so I'm 29 years old recently engaged to
love my life she's awesome
um
and I have a question about our kind of
situation so we both went through
Financial Peace University together a
couple months ago obviously doing it
together but keeping our finances
separate until we get married
um I'm in baby steps four and six she's
in baby step two so my question is
obviously we've been through Financial
Peace University but what can I do and
we do together whether it's from the
financial side or the relational side to
put ourselves in the best position
possible when getting married in July
how much does she owe
so she owes about two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars yeah you all should
break up man I'm totally playing don't
do that George don't do that don't do it
what is uh what's she do is she working
or is she still in school
sort of in school so she's in her
residency for medical school
so she all of her debt is the medical
school student loans so she's uh going
into year two starting here in a couple
weeks so okay so what will y'all's
income be when you get married
when we get married our income together
would be roughly 170 gross and they
would go way up after she's done with
residency
correct yeah okay are you able to cash
flow the rest of this you have two years
left after this or three years left
or she going to some sort of specialty
right so the the debt itself is done so
she's uh she's actively working in her
residency the schooling's gone okay
she's she's making an income now with
the wrestling team yeah it usually just
depends on the type of residency how
much longer does she have after this
she's in year two how far is she gonna
go
uh just two more years so two years
starting in July so she'll be done in
the summer of 2025. okay cool so you're
you're right on the path you're doing
all the right things keep the finances
separate she's running her own race
right now until you guys are married and
up until then what you can do is stack
up as much cash as you can obviously be
sure to cash flow all the wedding
expenses and once you're back from the
honeymoon we're gonna make that joint
account we're gonna lay it all out and
go how much debt do we have left how
much do I have in savings above the
emergency fund or even taking that down
to a thousand for a little while and how
can we clean this up fast and making 170
she has 220 in debt is that all of her
debt
correct yeah it's just the medical
school debt okay so looking at this I'm
like cool can we live off 60 and throw
110 at the debt and be done with this in
two years
and boom all of a sudden we're debt free
and now the income is spiked because
she's done with residency and now we're
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
completely debt free
soon into our marriage and here's the
cool part
um
I know they've they've actually dialed
back a lot of the hours on The Residency
um what's what's our hour load now
what's like an average week for her
it's a
traditional basis so an eight-week chunk
streets goes to different rotations
sometimes at 40 sometimes it's up to 80.
yeah it kind of depends on the location
I knew it used to be the days of the the
120 hours you sleep four days four hours
a week those are over but here's the
deal what George has said is so right
and if y'all look at your relationship
over the next two years
I can't think of a better time for you
all to constrict your discretionary
spending
because she's going to be working a lot
and you're going to be working a lot and
her head is going to be learning like
she's never learned before trying to
make sure people aren't Dead all that
stuff you're going to be learning how to
be married she is too young but this is
a perfect moment for you all to really
collapse your
big budget stuff and just budget for
food take your lunches make breakfast
together in the morning have dinner at
home when she's able to get home and
really constrict your day-to-day
spending
can you just imagine for a second she
walks across that stage at graduation
she is done she is a licensed medical
doctor and you all owe nobody anything
you realize you have won at that point
the cosmic Lottery
it's over that'd be amazing
yeah it's it's something we're
definitely looking forward to and day by
day taking you step by step there you go
man here we have for sure here's an
important thing and Dave's has taught me
this privately just us
sitting like it's just a blessing that I
get to sit by him and and and dig into
his wisdom
um keep their ratios in mind how much
money do you make by yourself at your
job
uh my current job I make 100 000 and
then I have a side hustle where I make
about five thousand a year okay so you
make a hundred grand and you're you're a
hard worker you're you got two jobs
going so you make 105.
220 000 sounds like a billion dollars
and it feels out of control and somewhat
insane
if you just extrapolate out the fact
that you're marrying a medical doctor is
going to make um salary X Y or Z down
the road the ratio of this debt becomes
a little bit more manageable and in
simpler terms you got a big hole but
you're going to have a huge shovel
to fill it back up with does that make
sense so keep those ratios in mind and
again George said it right man y'all get
a plan together and just don't deviate
from the plan stay on the plan stay on
the plan stay on the plan y'all gonna
look up in two years don't buy new cars
don't buy fancy Apartments you're gonna
look up at two years and owe nobody
anything your wife's gonna smile with
that big MD and you're gonna smile and
it's gonna be game on it's kind of
awesome I'm pumped for this George
you're on the path man you excited
absolutely yeah it's something going
through financial peace we got fired up
and now it's just you know I kind of
expected what you guys are going to say
to some degree but hearing it and
validating let me say this you know what
I want more than anything
I want an entire
swath of medical doctors to not have any
student loan debt you know why because
then they can practice medicine exactly
as their heart leads them
and they can practice medicine that is
evidence-based and not
um
not hospital administrator based
they can look at individual patients and
make individualized decisions because if
somebody gets mad that they quote
unquote stepped out of line who cares I
don't owe anybody anything
when you have a group of professionals
that are in that powerful of a position
that don't owe anybody nothing
then they can lead with their expertise
and their heart and now you've got as
Peter attia says you got medicine 3.0 at
that point they can stop you know what
I'm not gonna prescribe you medication
you start exercising and then when they
get enough complaints they can say okay
I'm just going to go to a hospital that
uh fill in the blank right so man good
for you this is the kind of your wife's
the kind of Doctor Who is going to
change the Health Care system for my
kids so good for you guys man I'm I'm
grateful that y'all as a couple exist in
the world man when's the wedding you got
a date
wedding is July 6 2024. oh you got some
time move it up what are you doing what
are we doing man
love of your life she's going to meet
some smoke show at some resident dude
I'm telling you move it up
uh I'll try I'll talk to her tonight yes
Justice of the Peace this weekend in the
meantime making a hundred grand for the
next year how much money could you save
up so that when you guys get married and
you have that joint bank account you go
honey I got 70 grand sitting here ready
to start knocking out this debt she's
gonna give you a big old smooch I'll
tell you that much right now gross that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books thank you so much for listening
appreciate my co-host Dr John deloney
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show float and you America will be back
before you know it
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney and
we are taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in if you've got that burning
question you need a third party who is
unbiased in a sense and a little biased
towards helping you get to freedom and
get to Wellness we are here for you
whether it's about your life your money
your relationships you name it triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Brandon is in Boise to kick us off
Brandon what's going on
hey good afternoon thank you for taking
my call sure how can we help
and get some
advice to navigate the baby steps after
a divorce
sorry to hear how fresh is this
uh currently ongoing
still going on okay not finalized yet
almost
man when you say almost I've heard
almost then roll out to be another year
so if you already reached a settlement
and signed everything
uh not yet uh everything has kind of
been drawn up and we're in the final
stages of uh going through reviewing and
signing okay so hopefully within the
next couple months
okay so
um what's the state what's the state of
your financial situation I know there's
a whole bunch of emotional stuff going
on the whole thing's of mass um what's
your financial situation
so
uh we We've ran the data frenzy program
about 12 years ago at FPU
paid off about 250 000 worth of student
loans wow
um and are currently debt free okay uh
outside of a mortgage
and as part of the settlement she's
going to get the house and everything
and uh refinance into her name
I'll be renting for uh at least a year
uh just to kind of
I don't want to make any big moves yeah
it's very very wise is she is she
writing you a big check for the your
piece of the equity there
no
there is
um uh due to discrepancy and
um wage earnings there's an unequal
division of property to offset uh it's
got some support
so you're not having to give any spousal
support as long as she gets the house is
that the idea
uh essentially yeah okay you'll have no
alimony on the back end
uh that's that that's the the current
agreement okay yeah it's still kind of
pending what happened
uh addiction
okay
how are you now you don't sound good
I'm struggling I'm not gonna lie yeah
are you struggling from the reality of
this are you struggling from the what
comes next what are you struggling with
everything
who's walking through this with you
do you have anyone in your community
friends professionals that are walking
with you
no it's just me
I need you to hear me say this is as
direct as I can and as as true as the
sun's gonna come up
you gotta have people that walk
alongside you in this dude you can't you
can't do this by yourself what was the
addiction
uh alcohol okay are you still drinking
oh it's not me no it's not you okay no
how long you all together
uh 11 years
do you have little ones
we do
have you guys figured out custody
yeah it's gonna be split it's gonna be
split down the middle is that safe
uh I believe so okay
um
one of the hardest things about being
married to somebody being in love with
somebody that struggles with addiction
so deeply
um
um is that you have that person in your
life but they're not there
and you spend it you spent a decade
trying to figure out what about the
situation was your fault right
yeah you've been trying to solve this
for a long long long time and there's
something to be said for
the closer this gets to reality the
closer this gets to finality
you're gonna have the sense that you
failed something
and I want you in the darkest moments
man I want you to remember at least my
voice telling you
you did everything possible to try to
make this thing work
and the challenges was that your wife
was sick and she's struggling
and you did what you could do and that's
not going to bring you Joy but it might
bring you just a glimmer of Peace okay
thank you thank you
and I want you to be very hyper Vigilant
about those kids
I'm trying to be that they're my they're
my entire Focus I know right now but
listen the greatest gift you can give
them is by making sure their dad's okay
because what they need is somebody
that's totally present because they
haven't had a present mom in a long time
have they
not not so much okay they need a dad who
can laser in and dad can only laser in
when dad's whole dad can only be whole
if he's got a gang
if he's got a couple of men in his life
that will show up at 2 A.M that he can
text at any time
if he's got a counselor that he can talk
to if he's got a group he's got to have
somebody in his life
because if not you're going to end up
using those kids as an oxygen master
that you can breathe to get through this
grief and that's not their job
right okay so you have to do the weird
uncomfortable awkward work of making
friends with people at work or inviting
people over or reach out to local church
whatever that looks like I'm just
telling you as sure as the sun comes up
you've got to have people in your life
to to make it the other side of this
thing okay
yes sir the fair
um so talk to us about
um baby steps man it sounds like you
don't owe anybody any money it sounds
like you're transitioning to a rental
property it sounds like
um
if I'm reading between the lines you
went way way way above and beyond
to make this divorce easy on her
and just said she can have the house and
I'm gonna I've got a much more viable
opportunity moving forward to get myself
another place you can get on your feet
you love this woman so much you can get
on your feet better than she can Fair
uh true and that's part of that you know
I get to keep the retirement accounts
that I had sure
um and everything else like that just
being clean where does this put you once
you're renting do you have a pile of
money and no debt
uh
um I have I'll get some cash assets uh
from the the property
um the shared property okay call that
your emergency fund hold on I want you
let's do this I want you to stay on the
line because we're gonna we're gonna
hold you over to um the next call we got
a commercial coming up but we're gonna
hang on to this because I want to finish
this call and make sure we give you the
amount of time that um the the since the
severity of this call uh entails so hang
on a line real quick brother we'll be
right back after this break
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney we were talking to our friend
Brandon in Boise before the break who's
going through a messy divorce dealing
with a spouse with addiction and little
ones involved in figuring out the next
steps both financially mentally
relationally and we've got them on the
line to continue helping him out Brandon
are you still with us
yeah I'm still here okay
cool cool so where did we leave off we
were talking about some of your finances
uh you said you were in good Financial
shape you're getting some Assets in cash
from this what does that look like
um so I'll probably get
um it's probably close to forty thousand
dollars worth of
um
money which I'm going to throw towards
building the uh my emergency fund okay
perfect
um what's your income
uh 200. awesome and that won't change
no okay and you said you're going to
rent for a year and then just figure out
what's next later on down the line
correct correct and then I'm just kind
of wondering because I have a bit of
money saved because I've been saving for
a number of years for retirement and I
probably have about four hundred
thousand in
um between Roth IRAs and 401ks
um and then should I you know given that
I'd like to buy a house and save up for
a house
um
do would you recommend pausing
putting into retirement to get a bigger
down payment and less of a mortgage for
a house
uh given that I I kind of have some
monies in there as it is or just kind of
keep going what the plan is outlined if
I made two hundred thousand dollars and
I had an emergency fund and I was
investing I would keep on investing and
shovel as much of that income into that
down payment
and if you're I mean you don't sound
like you're living super lavishly so set
a goal and say hey could I put away 100
Grand a year
into a high old savings account and just
let it sit there until I'm ready to buy
a house
you could have 200 Grand in two years
right
I hope so yeah
so so would you recommend then holding
off on retirement uh putting additional
funds into retirement for right now
until I save up that money I would just
because you're in this storm right now
if you're going to be out of this thing
in a few months it's okay to pause the
baby steps during a situation like this
until you know what's next
and so if you just want to pause and
stack up cash because we just don't know
what the next few months holds I mean
lawyer fees who knows deposits we just
don't know what's coming what those cash
assets will actually end up being so if
you want to pause for you know the next
three months and let this thing shake
down and once that the the dust settles
we can go all right we got 40 Grand
we're gonna get back to investing 15 I
make 200 Grand I have a goal to set this
much amount aside for a down payment and
we'll go from there
okay
so I think financially you're fine the
part that worries me is what John was
talking about which is the fact that
you're doing this all by yourself
do you have family nearby
I'm sorry do you have any family nearby
no all my family's on the East Coast was
there um Health scares or infidelity
involved
yes okay
um
tell me if I'm on the right track here
one of the things I hear most common
from somebody who's been in a
relationship with somebody where they
cheat on them
is that you lose trust in the
relationship you lose trust in the other
person but most terrifying is that you
lose trust in yourself
I should have known this was happening I
can't believe I just couldn't I knew
something was off and I didn't trust my
gut I just kept going I just kept
putting it off because I wanted this to
be okay over here
and there'd be comes over time and this
is this is kind of universal when you're
in love with somebody and you're trying
to make a relationship work with
somebody who's really struggling with
addiction is you find yourself separated
from you
and you find yourself way out on a limb
doing things and thinking things and
making being okay with things that are
so disorienting to who you are at your
core that you feel lost as though you
can't you don't even know the way back
to yourself does that make sense
yes and so when you find yourself like
that number one is we've we've kept
harping on this but I want you to hear
me say it other people can become your
lighthouse in the darkness when your own
feelings are not telling you the truth
because right now your feelings are
telling you it's all coming down
everything's falling apart you fail at
this you're the worst ever fill in the
blank those are lies they're not true
but it's really hard to Wade through
that when it's just you and an out of
control dopamine system and a serotonin
system that's left the building so
having friends to be like no we're good
we're going to the gym we're going to do
this hey I know you're about to send
this email don't send that email that's
all important well and good
um the other thing is is to have some
very clear
goals written down and goals not like
crush your goals bro not like David
Goggins kind of stuff I'm talking about
I want to get this much money as in a
down payment I'm going to write that
down and when I get that dollar amount
I'm gonna exhale
because your brain's going to want to
move the the the Finish Line on you and
it's going to want to move it again and
when I get this much I'm going to kick
my retirement full tilts again when I
get this much after seven months I'm
gonna start looking for houses and I'm
gonna buy in 10 to 12 months I think you
are wise beyond measure to wait six
months to a year to buy a house it's
super Super Wise because this whole
thing is sideways right now and it all
feels like a forest fire you get away
till the Smoke Clears but you write
these things down and you live and die
by these by these numbers that you put
down and you don't get carried away with
emotions and feelings during the time
when your emotions and feelings are all
over the place okay so those are the two
important things get people and get some
very clear metrics of success and
regardless of how you feel regardless of
whether you feel motivated or not we're
going to keep pushing ahead and taking
the little step in the little step in
the little step every step of the way
and remember this
greatest gift you can give your kids
right now is that their dad is okay
because those kids need peace and their
dad needs peace
and you give them that in the midst of
all this chaos that's a great great gift
so Dad needs to go to the gym dad needs
to hang out with friends dad needs to go
back to church dad needs to do those
things to keep dad whole and well and
that's going to be a great stabilizing
gift for those little ones thank you so
so much for the call my brother um
anything we can do to help you let me
know there's actually somebody out in
the lobby um from Boise that said they'd
love to be a contact for you so we'll
make sure we loop back and get you um
the opportunity um we're not going to
give them to your contact number but
we'll uh send you their contact uh
information if you if you want to reach
out there
um just somebody saying hey I'd love to
go hang out and get some nachos too the
other thing I'm going to do is send you
Dr John deloney's book own your past
change your future to help you grieve
what's happened to give you a picture of
how to move forward and we're also gonna
have our team send you a link to our
blog article from Dr John deloney it's a
divorce checklist that really walks you
through in detail of kind of what you
need to be thinking about right now
because you can't even think clearly and
so I hope this article helps we're also
going to link that article in the show
notes or the description wherever you
guys are listening out there or the
audience so that if you're going through
this you know someone who's going
through this you can offer them this
resource this article that Dr John has
put together because man there's so many
things to think about John the last
thing you're thinking about is that
checklist of okay what do I got to do
next what do I got to do next well you
just got 500 people telling you 500
different things you got your lawyer
telling you one thing let's go to war
and then you got your spouse who's not
well they're not whole or who broke your
heart but you still love them or you
they're still the mother or father of
your kid there's so much chaos then you
have the nuts and bolts like how much is
the house worth and the retirement
accounts and how do we split this up
I'll trade you this one for this one all
that mess then you got your buddies from
college like let's do this and then you
got your friends at work it's just so
much mess and having something where you
can just go through and say have I
covered this have I covered this have I
covered this
um it can be such such a gift yeah
that's huge and a huge key with any
divorce is not making any big Financial
changes you don't have to make just let
it sit six months 12 months don't make
any drastic changes because truthfully
it's hard to be thinking clearly and we
know that you know divorce turns
marriage into a business transaction and
so you do have to be thinking about okay
what about those retirement accounts let
me get my ducks in a row let me make
sure that the banks are separated if
they need to be separated be working
with professionals lawyers mediators
whoever is in your corner to help you
figure this stuff out you don't have to
do this loan whether it's Insurance Pros
you name it we can get you connected to
ramseysolutions.com to help with that
process and again we'll link the divorce
checklist article from Dr John in the
show notes or description wherever
you're listening or watching man that's
tough we're cheering you on Brandon uh
to figure out what's next create that
new picture to grieve to heal I know
you're going through this and so many
other people are and it's a tough tough
situation this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our Ramsay apparel has been flying off
the shelves and it's not just because
that stuff is cozy and fits nice it's
because people are proud of the progress
they're making with the baby steps and
they want to show it off to the world
and I love when folks visit us from all
over the country and they're rocking
that swag we're so proud of you guys and
that's why for a limited time we're
knocking five bucks off every single
Ramsay t-shirt sweatshirt and Hoodie
while supplies last you can choose from
your favorite Ramsay sayings like live
like no one else Cassius King better
than I deserve or I heart George camel
okay that one's not on there John but I
think that one's next that's actually
the reason why we're having to Discount
these to get them out of the building
because it's a fire safe there was three
people who bought I heart George
Campbell and they were all Whitney camel
your wife even she wouldn't Dawn
they were both comps right all three of
them are comps it's fine but there's
there's plenty better merch out there so
whatever Ramsay's saying is your go-to
we've got you covered but hurry because
once they're gone they're gone the swag
is limited time only so Wear and share
your story with five bucks offerings the
apparel for a limited time go to
ramseysolutions.com
store today
Sarah's up next in Nashville Tennessee
right down the road Sarah how are you
hi I'm good thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
so my husband and I are wondering should
we pay off his mom or the government
first for our student loans oh Sophie's
Choice I'm not sure which one's scarier
yikes
okay walk us through who is scarier she
knows Sarah knows
uh I mean I don't know if either one's
scarier but you know there's that
relationship of course with one can ruin
your life and the other is the
government
[Laughter]
all right so what are the debts
so we have 21
000 owed to his mom and we have about 28
000 owed to the government
the government being student loans or
taxes yeah no all student loans okay uh
what's this 21 000 to your to your
mother-in-law that she paid off our
private loan
okay so it's 49 000 in student loans
total
48 okay yeah yeah what's your household
income
uh 72 000. okay and how much money do
you guys have right now in the bank
uh we have you know about a thousand
dollars in savings and um I mean I
wouldn't say we would pay check to
paycheck but you know we got we got
enough to pay our bills and expenses so
okay any other debt or is this it no no
I mean beside their house no okay
and what's the agreement
oh one second what do you do for a
living
I own an event planning company and what
does um your husband do for a living
he's an illustrator and government
designer but he also stays at home with
our kids and homeschools them okay and
so who who who brings home the line
share the money
me what's your what do you make annually
uh I pay myself from the business 72 000
and so his illustration business
um is kind of here or there so it could
bring in a couple thousand a month and
then nothing the next month it's kind of
here and there
is there a possibility that
mother-in-law could keep kids for a
season while you and him doubled and
tripled and quadrupled down just to get
this debt paid off
um not the one that we're trying to
repay she doesn't live here okay
um my parents they are newly retired but
I don't know if they would take on both
of our kids here's what I'm saying you
guys are up for a tough tough slog
making 70 000 having to pay back almost
50. with um uh one parent stay-at-home
one parent
um with an event planning business
that's that is I mean you happen to be
in Nashville so that's great but it is
seasonal and it is up and down it is I
hope it works out
um
man a one year of y'all figuring out
what to do with child care and your
husband working three jobs and you
taking this job and then drive an Uber
in the mornings just knocking this crap
out of your life forever it's gonna
radically transform the peace inside
your home your ability to parent your
ability to run your business everything
changes if you all just take one year or
two years and just go like maniacs and
get this stuff done
I know it doesn't sound fun so which one
do you think we should focus on first
though I mean now that the interest
rates coming back on the government line
should we just knock that one out first
I mean truthfully I would pay a
mother-in-law first and it's not just a
debt snowball thing because the amount's
lower it's also because you don't have
to look the government in the eye over
dinner
yeah it's a very different situation and
everything you do she's watched every
vacation you I mean everything she's
going wait yeah they owe me money and
they're out here they just bought that
and so that's my other fear and I'm she
could be a wonderful person who doesn't
have that at all but she still gave you
guys 21 000 with the agreement that you
were gonna repay her so what what was
that agreement is there a certain amount
every month was there an interest rate
or was just pay me what you can when you
can
she kind of just told us to pay her 250
a month
um we've been we took a pause and was
not paying her for a year or so and now
we've really started to pay off like a
chunk at a time like a thousand dollars
at a time are you keeping track of this
yes okay is she keeping track of this
she I have it in a spreadsheet that she
has access to excellent okay I'm so glad
to hear you say that because the number
of people who call and like I gave you
10 grand like I only got four grand so
you get that mess with a family so good
for you for that yeah I honestly would
just figure out a way to even if it
means getting child care and your
husband can earn above and beyond that I
know he wants to be a graphic designer
and he wants to draw y'all dug yourself
a humongous hole so this is not the
season to
do the cool uh Millennial advice of
Follow Your Passion which is a terrible
idea all the time but you all got to
just run and Gun and Run and Gun and Run
and gonna get this crap paid off so that
then you can be about what do we
actually want to do with our lives it's
awesome good word all right let's go to
Brad in Seattle what's going on Brad
how much are you good how can we help
I had a question so I'm 24 years old and
I have uh I've saved up three uh sorry
over the last three years I've racked up
about 100K in my 401k
um and I have about 50k in my savings
cash
and I was wondering if what your guys's
opinions would be to use my 401k to put
a bigger down payment on a house
one to avoid you know PMI and then also
get a lower payment with the high
interest rates right now oh gosh okay
I'll I'll be truthful with you it's a
terrible idea
you're gonna avoid PMI but you're gonna
pay tons of penalties for withdrawing
that 401k
right so it's it's not even a wash
you're losing big time on this deal
so I would not Rob your future because
you've done such an amazing job I mean
you're such an impressive dude to have a
hundred thousand dollars saved already
in a 401k at your age to where I'm like
why ruin all that hard work and Rob the
growth while also paying penalties I
mean it's like taking a 30 loan on this
money
thirty percent interest rate uh loan so
um I would just pause and go hey if I
don't have enough I'm just going to keep
saving for another six months and just
delay this home purchase
right and the only big factor I was
considering is yes I'm still technically
losing money but uh 40 percent of that
was company match
um so I racked up that money really
quick
oh you're a guy that Vegas loves Vegas
loves you because you win a little bit
of money and you think it's just Vegas's
money and they keep you at the table
and then they take it all
once it's in your pocket bro it's your
money
what is causing you to feel this level
of urgency to where you're willing to
get punched in the face in order to get
into a home
well I'm still living at home
um right now are you wanting to get out
is it a family is a relational problems
that's one you're going I gotta get out
of here
now there's there's no problem I'm just
get an apartment man you said you were
21. at home 24. 24. okay get an
apartment dude I would go rent an
apartment if you can't afford it in
Seattle I'd get a roommate make it a
party for a while until you save enough
to do this the right way and that means
using your future income not your future
retirement that's what I would do if I
was in your shoes and I will sleep very
well knowing I steered you in the right
direction my friend thanks so much for
the call this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day comes from
Proverbs 12 11. those who work their
land will have abundant food but those
who chase fantasies
have no sense
it was Proverbs was predicting uh crypto
is that like the metaverse in crypto
right there
slash once said you can't wait around
for Destiny to give you what you think
you deserve you have to earn it even if
you think you've paid your dues that one
was just for John
I I think that's the most words I've
ever heard slash speak and slash even
say that I feel like they're trolling us
no I think he played that on the guitar
and we interpreted it well the other day
they gave me a Shaquille O'Neal quote
and someone was like Hey you know that
was Aristotle right I was like I thought
it didn't sound like Shaq no I think
that sounds like slash that's fine good
stuff I'm George Campbell joined by Dr
John deloney this is the Ramsay show and
up next we've got Michelle in Phoenix
what's going on Michelle
hi it's an honor to speak with you both
my question is is it financially smart
to take about a 50 000 pay cut to work
part-time and stay home more with my
one-year-old son and if you'd like I can
give you a little bit more background of
where we are in the steps and all of
that yeah run us through your numbers
yeah so I'm 30 my husband's 33 we're in
baby steps four five and six
um we currently make about
215k plus bonuses
um my portion of that income is 130k
um like I said I'd be going down
probably part time with the goal of
making probably 80k but I think that's
very it feels like a very high
goal for only working 20 to 30 hours a
week and our monthly mortgage payment if
it's helpful is 16.70 and we owe about
230 left
so
what do you do for a living
I'm a marketing campaign manager okay
where did you come up with the number of
80 000 at part time
good question uh trying to look at doing
like part-time work in fake configuring
like 20 to 30 dollars an hour plus
potentially adding freelance on the top
of that so combining that aiming for
maybe 70-ish dollars an hour combined if
that makes sense yeah so your husband
makes about 90 a year
yes that's right okay
um George you can run through the math
on this I would just tell you just given
a cursory glance I would
if you and your husband have decided
this is what y'all want to do I wouldn't
think twice about it
I wouldn't even think a third a a a
second about this now that is very easy
for me to say as a man
I don't have half of the world telling
me that I'm such a terrible human for
working while I have a child and the
other half the world telling me I'm such
a terrible human for all the all of the
sacrifice women made to get you in the
workforce you're just going to stay at
home with a baby like I don't have that
kind of guilt and pressure on me 24 7
365. okay not to mention my own career
aspirations that I've got a balance
between my own parenting aspirations
you've got a whole bunch more on your
plate than I do okay so it's easy for me
to say that from this position but
man if that's what's right for you and
your family that's what's right for you
and your family and it doesn't mean it's
going to be easy you are going to feel
guilty you are going to feel like I'm
not contributing I'm not doing X I'm not
doing well I remember we used to be able
to do this because I was work all those
things you're gonna feel
um this is where it's important to
choose guilt over resentment every
single time
I'd much rather feel guilty that I'm not
bringing in the money I used to be then
resent my co-workers and where I work
because I don't get to see my child
right one of those poisons in my body
the other one is is a natural part of
being alive George what do you think
about the numbers so Michelle here's
what I would you the way you phrase the
question was is it wise I don't think
it's a wisdom question it's a are you
willing to do whatever you have to do to
make that work and if that means we're
willing to cut our expenses down we're
willing to slow down the house pay off
we're willing to forego a vacation in
order for me to stay home because that's
what I want to do then great
but that's all you need to think about
is hey this action has a consequence can
we live with the consequence which is we
lose this income and if you're able to
make it work on let's say his salary
alone could you do that in the budget
um yes I think so it would pretty much
be about Break Even okay so if that's
the case I would sit down and make a
mock budget you can make a fake account
with every dollar with every dollar and
go hey if we just lived on his income if
I brought in zero dollars and decided
I'm not going to work another day can we
still cover the bills make ends meet
still invest for retirement and make
this work
how is there a period of time that makes
sense for how long you should be slowing
down for like or does that matter is it
a family decision like I just I don't
want to slow our financial goals so much
that we look back and we're like oh man
I wish I would have gone back full time
I mean to pay off the house we have now
and move into a nicer house I want to be
able to you know have more kids send my
kids to my schools because nothing like
concrete I guess just
you'll be making some trades no question
about it
also it's really easy to make trades
right now or be concerned about trades
your husband's gonna end up getting more
making more money
and you will be able to they'll figure
out technological ways for you to
continue to work from home and make good
money
and so you may have to it's like man I
really want to have this house or that
house or whatever house I promise you
what your kids really want is is a home
that is not anxious a peaceful home
and so you can have like we got to go to
this school or that school I don't know
man maybe the local public school is
great and we'll teach them the faith of
our choice at home where it should be
taught anyway like all these things that
that feel so heavy right now here's
here's the scary thing is this your
first kid
yeah how old
he's gonna be 12 months next month okay
you were okay the fog is lifted from
newborn and you're starting to look out
as this kid is is kind of bumbling
around the house and walking and kind of
babbling
a you're realizing your heart had
another chamber in it that you didn't
even know existed that you didn't know
you had the capacity for love like this
your husband too you also are realizing
what like it's almost as a parent you
look up and realize what an absolute
dumpster fire the world is like you know
about it when you don't have kids but
you feel it when you do and you're
realizing oh gosh we got to do this and
this and this and all that becomes that
angst and that Panic you know what I
mean that's when sitting down and saying
what are the choices we're going to make
for the next six months and let's just
ride six months and then at six months
let's revisit it and we're gonna make
the next change because your kid can
always just go back to school
you can always go back to work you can
always fill in the blank even if well
they're with this school and this school
and they really have good friends
they're six they're gonna be fine
they're gonna be fine but most parents
think at one year of age I've got to
make the decision for the rest of my
kids life and that's just they put so
much pressure they torture themselves
it's not real do six months at a time
maybe one year at a time your first year
out because the first six months you're
going to be getting your bearings and
you're an executive you're a stud you're
awesome at what you do you make 130
Grand working from home you're good
it's gonna be tough transitioning from
hey will you approve this will you
approve this to
poopy diaper poopy diaper poopy diaper
poopy diaper
um right hey what's for dinner right
that's gonna be a tough psychological
transition but you you can do it just
need a gang of women around you that you
trust but as you move forward let's just
make decisions six months at a time none
of these decisions are forever and it
should give you some peace knowing if I
don't like this in six months then we're
gonna change it and I'm gonna go back to
work and we're gonna say I gave it the
old College try and it did not work and
we're gonna do something else it's all
good
yeah is that cool okay yeah that does
that's let me just tell you my house in
my house we did private school for a few
years nope we did
um
wife working full-time she chose to go
part-time we investigated that for a
couple of years she stayed at home and
then now she's back to working part-time
kids are in public school we might move
them back to private school we just are
whatever season happens to show up in
our life we didn't know that when we had
our first kid that we'd be living that
was three jobs and two states ago who
knows what the world's gonna throw at
you just do it in little incremental
chunks and man keep that keep those
goals ahead of you but yes you're going
to make some trades and slow down yeah
and make peace with the decision don't
always think well if it was the other
way what if you just got to make this
that's right and nothing is fatal here
thanks so much for the question that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Dr John deloney all
the folks in the booth and you America
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
thank you
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]